jim's new book memoirs and
misinformation is now available wherever
books are sold by the way the cover of
the book is kind of funny because jim
took a picture off a screenshot of his
computer when
north korea was going to blow up hawaii
there was a real
serious alert about it it was a fake
alert but you didn't know it at the time
so that's a picture of you hearing the
news that hawaii was about to blow up
my assistant linda who uh who um at the
time was warning me that we had ten
minutes to live that the wow the
missiles were about to land
and she was clutching the phone so
tightly that she actually
accidentally took a screenshot and this
is my face
staring into the abyss this is my face
after i've been told i have 10 minutes
to live and so i just thought
that's just the perfect misinformation
that look what
you know what i went through because of
misinformation
you look like you have such pain in that
picture and i was like what the [ __ ] is
this picture
you know what it is it's more like oh
that's weird funny way for it to end
it's a weird thing to walk around the
world knowing how you'll be in the last
10 minutes of your life
and it was a surprise that i actually
slipped into this
place of gratitude of like going well
you know if it's gotta end it's like
what a what a life
what an incredible life so far it's been
amazing and i got to live on it's like
dickens man it's like it's still
christmas morning